as one of our best-known actors Lenny
Henry has long been an advocate of
increasing representation in film and TV
but this is about the talent behind the
camera
it's about key hires isn't it it's about
HR this and it clearly needs to change
the room it needs to be broadened we
need to be thinking about how can make
this work for everybody not just a few
and we need to take action but I'm very
aware that these things take time so
this is a this is a polite suggestion of
something that could be done the idea is
to give tax breaks to film and TV
productions which meet three or four
criteria incentivizing production
companies to hire more women disabled
people and those from black Asian and
minority ethnic backgrounds to better
represent the population the truth of
the matter is money talks so if you're
if if a production is going to benefit
financially they're more likely to act
on getting that financial incentive
[Music]
the letter describes a diversity crisis
with just over 2% of UK TV made by
directors of black Asian and ethnic
minority backgrounds and less than 14%
of directors are women we want people to
stop thinking about employing be AME or
different people as a risk you know look
at the vast amount of cultural product
this country produces from black people
Asian people gays trans people with
disabilities look at the creativity in
all these communities but add to the GDP
of this country one or celebrate that by
giving us a tax break for diversity the
government's film and TV tax breaks are
credited with boosting employment in the
sector so hopes are high they could be
the key to also boosting diversity lucy
casa sky news